another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do at the foundation when writing a  report more detail is expected than  object class scatter special containment  procedures  expunged description  expunged and inventing new security  clearances just so nobody can see what  you've written is also considered poor  form we know sometimes race can get a  little redaction happy we understand the  frustration but that's frankly no excuse  to fill your documents with nonsense and  then hide them from us if you keep doing  this we'll send technical researcher  rosen after you and we both know that  guy's a huge jerk mark our words dr  wright we are not bluffing even if you  do claim to have security clearance  level 420  nice